[Music]
leftover bags that
passer just left out there for whatever
reason
when passengers leave bags we got to go
through them
make sure there's nothing illegal
depending on the day
you can get about 30 40 yellow bees
they're the people that are
in a hurry and they think they're gonna
miss the flight and they'd rather leave
the bag behind
or the reason we check the person
might not want to get cut bring you
something and leave the big the back
behind
when i go through the bags i try and be
methodical i try not to overlook
anything
coffee beans can't really see
inside it i'm have to cut it open
got a coffee smell but we'll see what we
got
well coffee is supposed to be
brown right
coffee is not supposed to be white
now we just cut open the rest and see
and again
oh wow okay
try not to get too high too low because
you know you got to test it
but when you start seeing the same thing
you're like oh okay
that's not the norm
[Music]
they picked
oh yes he did so this was inside the
coffee
gotcha so do they look like commercially
packaged
yeah it looked legit let's see how it's
stitched
sometimes you just can't skip steps that
simple it's that easy
let's glue it on so now we're gonna test
it and
see what we have
what do you think that's cocaine man i
can smell
i don't it
it's all right there you go it's reading
cocaine
hydrochloride so
that's cocaine it's just straight
cocaine
no mixture no nothing else so you know
it's a good day
nice catch
3.51 kilos
[Music]
wow almost eight pounds yeah that's a
lot
since i've been here this is one of the
largest ones we've had that's over a
year and a half
you